good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday that feels
like a Monday for your girl cuz I wasn't
on yesterday but I'm back baby back back
in the toasty
Groove yeah I'm back hey
Jack is there a question there how you
ding daring good thank you welcome back
L Deo oh my God thank you so much not
only am I back on the toes I feel like
I'm back to life I've just been I have
not left my house in days I have like
not showered I look like a disgusting
rat and so today like my hair is done my
makeup is on like I feel I don't know
I'm just feeling like myself again I
love that for you how is due the
question on everyone's
mind let me say this has been a horrible
week like maybe one of the worst of my
life top five for
sure
um depends when you ask Theo is okay
he's totally fine he's like he's stable
he's stable he's feeling good he's
eating he's cuddling with his parents
like all signs he's on Med so I I don't
believe he's in pain that's like one of
my number one concerns cuz I don't want
to you know be doing this like selfishly
like I want to be doing it for Theo not
for me
um so if you haven't been like following
my stories I'll just give like a quick
you know update the last time I was on
the toast Thea was in the hospital he
had these two tumors they are cancerous
they have spread quite aggressively um
surgery is not an option we can't remove
the tumors because it's you know it's
everywhere it's in his bones
um chemotherapy is really not an option
they don't think it'll work
so it's terminal it's like a it's a very
bad diagnosis
um so yesterday we started radiation
which was like really our only treatment
option for
him it's once a week for the next couple
of weeks he did very well
yesterday the it's it's palea radiation
so we're not going to it's not Curative
like we're never going to cure this but
in the ideal scenario this radiation
would significantly decrease the size of
his tumors and he could go back to you
know living a somewhat normal life but
with cancer ideally his pain would
decrease his discomfort would decrease
and this would extend his life now
there's no guarantee that this works uh
we'll probably know by next week for the
second appointment if the first one made
any sort of Headway with decreasing the
tumor um if it doesn't
work we cross that bridge yeah when we
get there
[Music]
um so yeah it's been really hard it's
like I think when you like
sorry like I'm sure like everyone can
attest this including you like when
you're a pet owner like you always think
about this like it pops into your mind
like once a week and you're like that
day will never
come and it's like just like always
something you're like constantly afraid
of so now having confronted it with like
my first you know dog that I own we had
a dog growing up but like as an adult
it's so much harder than I could have
like really ever imagined I also think
like this is a particular like tough
situation I don't know how like most
dogs and their life but ideally it's
like old age with Theo's breed we've
always been prepared for like later in
life him having a heart condition it's
it's genetic for their breed so we're
always like super on top of what they
eat making sure they don't get
overweight always keeping heart health
in mind yeah and this breed doesn't have
like the longest of years and we've
always known that but this is much
shorter than anything else yeah like
with a Cavalier if you get to like 12
you're really lucky but most of them
start developing like heart issues
around like 9 or 10 so I was prepared
for that I was not prepared for this
like out of nowhere left field
aggressive cancer spreading really quick
at the age of six like every and it
doesn't make me feel better but like
every doctor we talk to he's like shook
like it just doesn't like this should
not be happening it feels really unfair
yeah no it is it is and I'm so sorry and
you're doing everything you're doing so
amazing you're being so amazing for Theo
he has the best care he has the best
parents I just like don't I'm like
afraid that I'm being selfish we were
told at the emergency room that on
Wednesday once they did like the full
biopsy and everything we were like
strongly encouraged to put him
down but um we didn't
and I think that you know we were told
that like most people who go to the
hospital who are in Theo situation like
we we were we did a CT
scan um which showed like really like
the the amount that it had spread and it
was like $1,800 and and she was like you
know most people can't even do the the
CAT scan so
like I feel you know torn because I'm so
grateful that I was able to do all this
and provide everyone on my Christmas
list is getting coal like I'm I'm
literally giving it everything that I've
got um and I know so much for secret
santa yeah I know that if I was in like
a different situation um my options
would be more limited and I'm really
grateful that I have these options but I
just don't I'm so afraid of like doing
this just for me you know no but you've
been thinking about that every step of
the way you know when he's in pain you
know right now that he's on medication
and he's not in pain he's actually been
quite happy at home he's eating cookies
you know he's homesick from school he's
getting the perks I don't think that
he's in pain right now and I know that
when the time comes that you'll make the
right decision for him I just really
really hope that
um this radiation like makes some sort
of Dent like just a little like I mean
it would be like she had seen like a
similar dog situation who had over a
year and she was like I was shook
there's no way to know like cancer is
just so mysterious everyone's different
so there's a chance it's one month and
it's there's a chance it's three years
like there's just no way to know so I
know for a fact that like so many people
have messaged me that like they're
praying for Theo and like from all
different you know denominations and I I
just I know that works like I know it
does it has to so I'm really
appreciative and like honestly me and
Ben were talking about like how like so
when we picked him up from the hospital
on Wednesday the timing could not have
been worse going into Thanksgiving
weekend so we had been doing all this
research on clinical trials and we were
calling all these different clinics and
no one was in so our goal goal was just
to keep him stable and comfortable from
Wednesday to Monday we just had to make
it to Monday because we could not get a
single individual on the phone via email
anything until Monday so we did that and
I felt like really optimistic on Sunday
night I was like oh my God we did it and
then on Monday I was just like okay I
did it but we have no sort of plan or
like no hope and so taking him to
radiation yesterday like felt good it
was like the first time I've been able
to be proactive inad of just like
keeping him stable now I feel like we're
actually fting um so in that sense I
feel good but like the just it's so
unknown if it's going to do anything and
I'm just I'm trying really hard to be
positive but it does I feel like I keep
saying this to B like I feel like I'm
being punished like what did I do it's
so
unfair
so it's okay he's going to be okay well
the big First Step you made it to Monday
and honestly there were points last week
where who knew that that was even going
to be accomplish so step one check you
just keep doing the next right thing and
you'll know what's right you'll know
what in your gut I feel so also
like so grateful for like the community
that we've made like I
seriously there's so many people who
have helped me in the last week that I
know personally from the toast like the
hospital that Theo was at you know the
head of oncology sister is a toaster and
so we were able to connect with her over
the holiday when really not a lot of
other oncologists were working her name
was Nicole leem and she was amazing um
I've had just so many people helping me
like from the Cavalier Alliance her name
is Tanya she's amazing she's just been
like you know helping me with medical
stuff but also just like talking me
through like literally being so upset
um there's just so many people and I
will I I want to thank everyone but um
really what I'm praying for like
everyone just send the most positive
love and light to Dr Carrie Rosen in
Yonkers like her Theo's fate is in her
hands she's amazing so I was like going
through my messages because people have
just been so helpful and this girl was
like I have had two dogs with cancer you
have to go see the specialist in Yonkers
I'm like wait is it Carrie Rosen she was
like yeah she told me her whole story
she sent me like all of her medical
records like just everyone has been so
helpful and so wonderful and I'm so
grateful so I have to just really focus
on the positive like one that I'm able
to provide this level of care for Theo
like I'm very very blessed to that there
are so many people like in my personal
life like so many people have been
texting me sending flowers cookies so
many of the brands that we work with
that sponsor the show like theal like
touched every touches everyone he does
so like I I have to focus on that like
I'm very very blessed in my life for the
platform that we have like the the
resources that you were able to like the
access information yeah information like
the was on a bunch of herbal like so
many people were like I know it sounds
crazy but like holistic andb Pet Care is
like legit and I first I was like okay
sure but like everybody kept saying like
the same couple of herbs they're like I
swear to God turkey tail I swear to God
unin bio like I'm going to the holistic
pet store today
like access to that sort of information
from people who have experience is an
enormous privilege and I'm very very
grateful so I really need to focus on
like the good that i' I've been able to
do and hopefully will continue to do but
honestly this has been one of the
hardest things like I've really ever
ever dealt with in my life and honestly
what's so weird is like this
obviously isn't my first experience with
like grief but it is my first experience
with like hopefully not but like
potentially like losing someone over
time I feel like anytime I've lost
someone it's been so sudden like with
daddy like we just found out one day he
wasn't sick like he just had a heart
attack and people always compare like
would you rather know would you rather
be able to say goodbye or would you
rather not and honestly this is so much
harder this is so much worse like for
real yeah and I just like I knew it
would be difficult I thought you know
500 years down the line it is much much
harder than it's one of the most
challenging things I've ever dealt with
in my adult life like for real that
makes sense and you're not wrong for
feeling that way
it's it's
heartbreaking but you're doing like we
have to focus on the positive theot he's
doing well he's eating he's eating he's
got his diaper on yeah his di he's ready
to take on the world the first few days
and I don't want to compare because I
know it's like rude and I'm not a mother
I know that but this is I think the
closest I'll really ever get to like a
newborn phase like we are up throughout
the night we are changing diapers we are
putting him back to sleep we are giving
him medication we are taking him out
like a couple times a night and then of
course all throughout the day
yeah wow
wow wow I will say like Ben will be the
best dad like if I'm like I'm doing 40%
he would probably argue that I'm doing
less like he's doing so much so I'm
trying to like you know pick out
positive things like Ben will be a
wonderful father we'll be great parents
I know it like I'm trying to you
know I'm try there like I feel like
there's a lesson to be learned here like
what is the message I'm being sent from
God like it's not for you to have to
parse out the message while you're going
through it you know don't it would make
me feel better to like no you'll get
there yeah you'll get there I've been
thinking a lot about maybe getting
another puppy cuz I've heard that like
young Spirits can really reinvigorate
they say like senior dogs or sick dogs
Ben's like not into it he's like why are
we replacing Theo I'm like we're not
we're helping him then I also think like
when the time comes you know in 100
years where Theo's time is up like I
think it would be easier on us yeah so
I'm just thinking through a lot of
things well I love the idea
of baby do
baby baby do Theo would love it the all
the niblings would love and welcome with
open arms so it's just been such a crazy
week I'm so excited to be like back
doing mindless [__] like it's been just
eight days of heaviness and I want to
just talk [__] I want to just think
about anything else but this but I
wanted to get everyone an update
obviously great well thank you for the
update thank you for being here of
course oh my God I really wanted to be
here yesterday yesterday was such a busy
day I will say like I'm taking any
appointment I can get for the Radiology
but like the next couple of ones how's
10:30 I'm like no it's great thank you
so much we'll just have to work around
them that's fine it's you know it's that
time of year anyway it's a holiday
things come up we've got to do early
we've got to do late things happen so
when we dropped Theo off at Radiology
yesterday it was two hours and they were
like you can go like you can't even be
here so you can either sit in the
waiting room or like go do stuff so we
explore the yers beautiful like
absolutely stunning went mini golfing it
was actually so much fun
um and we just really felt like when we
walked into that place where the like
the animal hospital where Dr Queen
Carrie Rosen will hopefully bring my boy
back to life
um we were like such positive energy we
really felt like Carrie was some sort of
like witch in a good way like she has
some sort of powers like I'm telling you
I have a good feeling about it that's
good Positive Vibes only it's so hard it
for me especially but like I think for
anyone in the situation but given the
fact that I'm like the most negative
[__] on the planet it's been really
hard I feel like you are being very
positive and and mentally healthy about
this as much as you can be while also
like experiencing the emotions of it
every time I like when be and Ben are in
the house alone for a really long time
and like we don't talk to anyone it gets
really dark and we're only one of us is
allowed to like cry be weak at one time
like if I'm crying Ben is not allowed to
cry he has to be like the positive one
and when Ben cries I'm like Ben it's
fine like we have been ping ponging but
when we don't like see other people it
gets really hard but we had family
coming over all weekend like Ben's
parents came my family came like and
every time they come like I do feel
better yeah and Theo always like he
can't really move around a lot but like
when people walk in the room like he his
head perks up it's people he knows and
loves like his camping school friends
and his tail wags so like every time
people come over like I do feel so much
better every time like I FaceTime you
like I feel better but it's it's really
hard you need
buoys I I need need buoys I was
wondering this morning does the dog
walking crew know what's going on yeah
that's been honestly like one of the
hardest parts is like telling people in
my life who see Theo all the time who
love him so much oh I didn't mean to
make you upset no it's okay but like we
you and I when you lived here we shared
a housekeeper and she loves loves loves
Bruno and Theo so much loves they love
her so she had come on Wednesday when
Theo was still at the hospital and I
hadn't told her and she was like where's
Theo and I just like started crying and
she started crying and you know she's
been praying for Theo and then I spoke
to a lot of the um old door men in my
building yesterday cuz I had some
packages and they called me they're like
you want to pick it up and I wanted to
tell them cuz they love Theo of course
his dog walker Jonathan who loves him so
much has been texting me his groomer so
he touch he touches so many people yeah
and that's been really hard he has his
community and his friends that's been
one of the hardest parts damn when
you're like a ray of light everyone you
shine on feels you know they feel the
darkness when you're not there it's so
true shine on Theo shine on well I have
my Theo pillow here with me Bruno and I
thinking of Theo all day every day and
we'll get through this we will get
through this I just like I need it to be
over you know but like in a good way
yeah just the I know okay well I'm going
to do my best to boo you today that's my
job how are you I mean after that I
don't know I'm I'm good I think and yeah
no I'm good just busy busy time of year
as I was saying with Liv on the toast
yesterday we had a very fun time jolly
good fun on the show
yesterday and yeah just enjoying this is
the greatest time of year I know you're
having a hard time but we have to
acknowledge the space that we're in
between Thanksgiving and Christmas tury
Lou I know I feel like it's like passing
me by when we were driving up to joners
last night I was looking around all the
trees were bare and I was like what the
[__] happened to fall I missed the whole
whole thing you didn't miss the whole
thing I did I'm missing everything it's
not too late it's not too you're still
going to see the snow by
Christmas yeah take Theo to see the
lights yeah I got to get him a stroller
I'm one of those people now my dog has a
stroller and a diaper by the way get
your dog a stroller I'm about to get one
for brew he just loves to be strolled oh
I got to go to the pet store today thank
you for a rem and you need to get your
holistic pets yeah no he needs his unin
bio apparently ever it's like a Chinese
everybody's like I'm here for it try
everything what's like what's the
downside with that stuff hope I don't
Jackie I don't even know who I am
anymore I made an appointment with a pet
psychic okay and what are you hoping to
glean that like she can just tell me
what is going on in Theo's mind okay
like Mom keep fighting Mom I'm okay you
know yeah yeah okay that would be good
information to have yeah I'm just so
desperate I'm trying things like I
probably would have made fun of someone
for and that's why I'm a [__] and I'm
the worst no it's just you never you
have to learn you have to walk in
someone's shoes you're learning so are
you going to see a pet psychic yeah when
I don't know I miss the appointment on
Friday I forgot I was like so busy is it
like Zoom yeah that's a Croc I know you
have to go in person no but she came
really highly recommended over Zoom she
came really highly recommended Claudia
no I know find to in person they have to
get their hands on pause no I now pause
for pause pause for pause yeah
okay back to booing I know everything's
just going to come back to Theo but how
I I'm going to try not to I'm really
going to try like I really want to
escape like I need the this show needs
to do for me what it does for other
people great and that's on me today
that's I'm going to take that on okay so
let me just Steward this ship without
further Ado let's get into some mindless
news that's going to take Claudia's mind
off of Tings even though I just brought
it up again here are the fast five
stories that you need to know and the
fast five stories that you need to know
are brought to you by State Farm the
State Farm personal price plan helps you
create an affordable price just for you
the plan's all about being personal to
you and your needs so that means you get
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
most importantly an affordable price
just for you because after all life is
just better when you can personalize
your experiences so think about it like
this from your go-to coffee orders to
your favorite pair of sweatpants we know
that you love to personalize your entire
day just like we do so Jax and I two
girls so similar we regurgitate the same
thoughts we finish each other's
sandwiches but we are
so different from what we wear to what
we eat to what we drink our favorite
midafternoon snack our favorite ways to
relax and then of course our insurance
needs I mean Jaxon is a homeowner she
lives out of state she's got a lot going
on she's got dependence okay that
requires a totally personalized
insurance plan so does mine even though
my life has a lot less meaning so
personalization just makes everything
that much better and State Farm believes
that insurance should work the same way
it's your plan it's your coverage
selections and it can all be
personalized to you and that's the way
it should be because nothing is more
personal than Insurance not even comedy
not even food not even poetry so like a
good neighbor State Farm is there prices
vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary let me just try that one more
time like a good neighbor State Farm is
there not my best but it'll do thank you
State Farm today's episode is also
brought to you by story worth this
holiday season I want to give a gift to
all of our loved ones that makes them
feel special and unique just like the
relationship that we share and that's
why we're giving everyone we care about
story worth an online service that helps
you and your loved ones preserve
precious memories and stories for years
to come it is a thoughtful and
meaningful gift that connects you to
those who matter most so every week
story worth emails your relative or
friend a thought-provoking question of
your choice from their vast pool of
possible options each unique prompt asks
questions you've never thought of
thought to ask like what's the bravest
thing you've ever done in your life or
if you could see into the future what
would you want to find out Jackie what's
the bravest thing you've ever done in
your
life going on a wellness retreat by
myself that's a good one I would say
mine would be pursuing standup oh for
sure that's one of but I think that's
tails in comparison no by the way yours
is beyond
fighing so after a year of questions
like that story worth Will compile all
your loved one stories including photos
into a beautiful Keepsake book that
you'll be able to share and revisit for
generations to come so it's like a
Year's worth of fun and like
thought-provoking moments but then you
also get to memorialize it all it's
really so thoughtful and so different
reading the weekly stories will help you
connect with loved ones no matter how
near or far apart you are with story
worth we are giving those that we love
the most thoughtful personal gift from
the heart and preserving their memories
and stories for years to come go to
storyworth.com toast and save $10 on
your first purchase that's storyworth
wth.com toast to save $10 on your first
purchase I love this gift today's
episode is also brought to you by the
farmer's dog the results of switching
your dog's food from cable to Fresh can
seem like magic when a senior dog starts
acting like a puppy again and the
pickiest of eaters can't wait for dinner
time you might think that some spells
were cast but the farmer's dog doesn't
use any sorcery or secret ingredients to
make their fresh food just science so
the farmer's dog makes and delivers
fresh healthy dog dog food it's
developed by bets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from real healthy
ingredients to human food safety
standards it's the best option for dogs
at all life stages because it's not
kibble it's not canu it's just real
healthy food traditional dry and wet dog
food options are highly processed and
they can use much lower quality
ingredients than they claim to and they
are extremely difficult to portion
accurately well the farmer's dog isn't
just fresh higher quality food they also
send the food pre-portioned specifically
for your dogs specifications based on
their unique nutritional needs this
makes it easy to help your dog maintain
the ideal weight which is one of the
biggest indicators of a full healthy
life dogs at a healthy weight can live
up to 2 and a half years longer than
overweight dogs and a fresh diet has
been found to have all sorts of benefits
from healthier coat and skin to better
breath even easier digestion and smaller
better poops so a healthy diet isn't
just important for humans as We Know all
too well our dogs are the most important
things in our life and really what you
put in their bodies every day is the
beginning of their journey and so do the
best do the farmer's dog it doesn't
matter if your dog is young or old it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health helping you guys live
more happy healthy and full years
together get 50% off your first box of
fresh healthy food at thefarmersdog.com
toast plus you'll get free shipping but
only when you go to thefarmersdog.com
toast go to thefarmersdog.com toast to
get 50% off your first box and free
shipping thank you la you're welcome our
first story Linda Evangelista is making
news by saying that she's not interested
in dating right now she said quote I
don't want to hear somebody breathing so
Linda evangela is really one of the most
quotable people she's going viral again
her first moment was I won't get out of
bed for less than $10,000 right right
and now um she did an interview with the
Sunday Times when she was asked about
dating she said I'm not interested I
don't want to sleep with anybody anymore
or I don't want to hear somebody
breathing and I think that's a really
important Point she brought up you know
about breathing yes and I know that this
is something that you can relate to no
we literally last night like Theo came
up to like lay between us and we were
like oh my God so we were just like
laying on him and it was such a nice
moment Ben was breathing so loud and so
I I just couldn't help it I'm like
breathe louder breathe louder and he had
the absolute audacity to blame Theo
how did he work that one he said it was
Theo oh he the was breathing like that
wow I'm like trust me I know both of you
in my bones and I know that breath
anywhere that was H your husband is the
Breather like I he's the he's actually
really more so the cougher but yes he is
also the Breather even in his Instagram
stories you hear him breathing in the
background oh good oh good so I'm not
crazy no like he just breathes my
husband and I like we don't breathe you
definitely don't breathe I don't breathe
Zach really doesn't breathe I I honestly
I can't relate to this oh my God Ben
breathes and he breathes and then he
breathes again it is so unacceptable and
I know it sounds crazy but I'm like I
just need you to stop breathing now I'm
not saying I want you to die but you do
need to stop breathing you need to stop
taking
breaths in in the manner in which you
you are breathing currently right I feel
like maybe Linda evangelie says like
past lovers and husbands were breathers
because that's like why she must enjoy
sleeping alone so much at this point and
she's I love Mak because when I say
something Ben's just like you're
critical like you're crazy you're you're
oversensitive that's why I love making
content with Ben because all the things
that he does like I get validated even
we did a patreon episode over the
weekend and me Ben and Theo like we
couldn't leave the room so Ben and Theo
just had to listen to the podcast how
many times did he cough in the
background oh I didn't hear it I was
busy pumping so okay like a
like I just love that there's
documented examples right and now he has
his own podcast you think that he is
like secretly taking out some of his
bodily functions I know that Josh um
like edits a lot of the episode for like
continuity when they're on Zoom like
they remove delays and stuff I have to
imagine Josh is removing I should ask
him like five to 10 coughs an episode
I'm ask and throat clears right no those
are all the same to me
right that I've been clearing my throat
a lot because it's like you know phase
12 of my sickness right and it's so
weird it I well do it there's other
people in the room it feels like I'm
about to say something but I'm not I'm
just like when you edit Good Guys
episodes comma How many times does Ben
clear his throat and did I say that
right and do you edit it
out okay I think that makes sense I'll
wait for him to respond he's on La time
so we'll see if he's
awake I look forward to hearing back
yeah so anyways Linda
Evangelista has a tury like situation I
saw like a funny funny tweet because
this this thing went so viral and there
were like random headlines and he was
like this is joining the headline Hall
of Fame and the others in there were
like we're so classic hold on I need to
find it it was so funny please do I'm
like a grandma try head line hall of
fame I should have like saved it or
something I know you always I always
save the things I never need and I don't
save the ones that I'm constantly
looking for now I don't even know who
said
it was it on Instagram or Twitter
Twitter which is just so hard to
find but if it if the text was headline
Hall of
Fame I don't know if they said Hall of
Fame [__]
it's there were some Classics in there
damn J Josh responded haaha who knows
okay thanks for
[Music]
nothing literally useless he didn't know
he was being put on the spot yeah no I
like him we were conducting research no
I'm always doing that on the toes like
trying to prove a point and so sending
text to people and like either they
respond to me and they totally negate my
point or I forget and then after the
show ends I'm like oh why did Josh peek
text me no totally you need to send like
a disclaimer at the Top This is for
research purposes we are live recording
the toast your answer will be live
broadcast and it does have implications
no you know at the beginning of like
most podcasts on dear media it's like
this is a dear media production I should
just send that little voice memo so
people know on air yeah yeah we are like
and you know what give us a little
something you know like right do a flip
stir the pot stir the pot do a flip a
flip yeah anyways um Linda
Evangelista quote Queen anybody if
anybody finds that tweet just send it to
me she needs me on brainy quotes you
remember brainy quotes remember I mean I
used it like yesterday actually I was I
actually did why because I wrote a
speech I spoke at a United hella event
and they wanted me to speak and I was
trying to find a particular
quote um and I went on brainyquote.com
what was the quote and did you find it I
was trying to find the quote that you
always quote from Game of Thrones but I
wanted to get the exact wording okay and
they had it on there we've been saying
it like a little wrong but I liked our
version better so I kept it what's the
brainy quotes
one it's not the brainy quotes one it's
the it's the Game of
Thrones hold on I remember one time in
college by the way do you know who said
it
uh I think of the accent someone not
like this it's not like Tyrion yeah no I
was surprised when I was doing my
research it was Lord uh varis the unic
that makes sense yeah that feels
right um said that was imitable
words who no wait who uttered those
Immortal Immortal words Margot Ash on
the redhe heads oh did she right yeah
every time we do a rating for the book
and we do the average in every single
episode like accidentally it's not even
on purpose she goes that feels right
that's so cute that's just her like not
listening no it's just it feeling right
because that's what the average rating
is it's a representation of how we all
feel about the book and it feels right
it should feel right yeah I kep find the
thing I was looking for but you know
what I mean you I I stand by I I use
brainy quote you use brainy quote cool
one time honestly brainy quote is is the
same as rhymezone.com yeah but just for
a different purpose yeah no a different
Journey a different Journey are you
ready for our next story yeah that
Claudia uh sent my way oh good I meant
to ask you if you chose this as a story
of course tury Mark Cuban announces his
plan to exit Shark Tank after season 16
it's time he said Mark Cuban believes
his time on Shark Tank is coming to an
end the billionaire businessman revealed
that he will not be returning to ABC
series after season 16 he said this is
our 15th year and next next year our
16th year is going to be my last year so
I got one more to go he said on all the
smoke podcast he said he feels it's time
to leave the series after first
appearing as a guest in season 2 and
joining full-time in the third season I
didn't realize he wasn't an original
shark I did because when they play those
really really old grany episodes like
where there's vaseline on the lens on
CNBC there's that guy Jeff Foxworthy
It's So Random the guy who hosts are You
Smarter Than A Fifth Grader wow wait
actually I don't think that's the same
guy hold on
hold on meanwhile Mark said that he is
grateful for the impact of the series I
love it because it sends the message of
the American dream is Alive and Well I
feel like in doing Shark Tank all these
years we've trained multiple generations
of entrepreneurs that if somebody can
come from Iowa or Sacramento or wherever
and show up on the carpet of Shark Tank
and show their business and get a deal
it's going to inspire generations of
kids that's what happens right now we've
got people coming on saying I watched
you when I was 10 years old I'm like
[__] but we're helping them right I'm
invested in I don't know how many
hundreds of companies yes by the way
Jeff Foxworthy like isn't that weird the
same guy are You Smarter Than A Fifth
Grader that is weird um I was shocked by
this news I never thought much about
Shark Tank ending or any of them leaving
it's just kind of one of those things
it's it's like stagnant it's just it's
always there and but it's also the way
the formula is it could go on forever
because it's a revolving door we don't
need mark on every episode but but for
isn't on every episode there's like to
like permanently exit feels like the
beginning of something yeah and I was
just shocked by this cuz shark tank is
almost like a soap opera you know it
just goes on and people love it and it's
not going to change the world but it's
just like it's something that I come to
rely on almost and I was really shocked
by this I never thought much if you had
asked me before this who would be the
first to leave like I wouldn't I I would
have never had that thought on my own I
I agree but now in thinking about
it he makes sense to be the first to
leave I agree cuz a lot of the other
sharks
are known sharks you know and being a
shark is like such a big part of their
brand and like such a big part of who
they are and I feel like for Mark maybe
not that you could really outgrow the
tank but like he doesn't want to be in
the tank he is famous outside of the
tank yeah the most famous outside the
tank now the show will and can go on
with the other sharks there are enough
sharks um but but I was really shook by
this yeah but it make like it it's not
like he wants a future in TV it's not
like you don't bite like leave a good
thing it's not like Bethany leaving
Housewives his show he was famous and
Rich before yeah and maybe in some ways
being a shark is a little
limiting I mean you know they're on ABC
so your your contract is with Disney
like there's probably it's definitely
limiting in what other opportunities you
can do no but also just like oh here
comes the Shark Tank guy like when he's
you know in a room of VCS and like all
these big investors and it's like maybe
Shark Tank seems
like I don't I don't feel this way I
don't feel Shark Tank to me is the
biggest name in business I'm just
speaking like whatp knob would say yeah
that maybe shark tank is a little
Pedestrian by the way people could like
fancy business people could see shark
tank as pedestrian but I think you know
Mark's business and success like speaks
for itself
right but maybe he wants to take that
one pedestrian thing out of his
portfolio while he continues onto big
glamorous things who do you think would
be the last person to leave Shark Tank
and why would it be Robert
herc I actually think it would be Mr
Wonderful because he is the show he is
he's the heart of the show like without
wonderful the show is not the same I
think without Mark the show will be very
much the same I think without wonderful
it would be neverful you know what it
would be it would be not
wonderful that's actually a really good
point I don't think they've considered
that definitely not but do you think
that like everyone all the other sharks
are shook no or do you think there's
like behind the scenes like drama I
don't think there's really drama cuz
they're all like so established and
they're all like rown adults you know
who aren't like and and said the tank
isn't like all they have in this world
and they're going to fight tooth and
nail to stay in it true they have so
much going on I think they're just like
hey hey hey so there are six sharks
right one of them is always revolving so
now I guess
all all of them will be or someone who's
been like a a fan favorite guest might
now become a full-time shark like or
someone who's guested a lot yeah like
but it's like there's always it's never
all the sharks there together like no
right that's what I'm saying so it's
it's five sharks at a time but there are
six sharks I don't know what the lineup
is honestly like cuz I feel like Barbara
there's Noh the episodes so it's yeah
Barbara Damon are like always
interchangeable I feel like Lor's always
there Robert is sometimes not there but
I feel like Lori Mr Wonderful and Lori
and Mr Wonderful are always there yeah
okay so there's I want to there's six
it's Damon Robert Mark wonderful Barbara
Lori right I didn't forget anyone no I'm
looking at a picture that's them so yeah
now I guess either it'll be all five all
the time or it might be exciting to add
someone new yeah or to give someone a
promotion that's been a guest like right
who's like currently like a famous
businessman like Elon Musk but he's like
too rich and famous for that but like
who's someone like that
uh feel like there's always like random
businessmen running for president like
one of those people thec I'm that's by
the way that's what I was saying if it
doesn't work out he can join the tank I
was thinking but is he a businessman
yeah yeah right like someone like
that or like that everybody loves that
guy Chris um he wears the bolo tie GoPro
yeah the GoPro guy he could get the the
promotion also the kind bar guy I was
just gonna say that he could get
fulltime but I do think um or like Sarah
Blakeley if she that's what I was gonna
say having a woman who's also like
famous like Sarah Blakey is really fam
like I knew who she was before she came
on the tank the other two I didn't know
them and she owns a basketball team so
like it would kind of be like similar to
Mark yeah I don't need it to be a famous
person I needed to be someone who's like
going to make good deals and that has
the money make deals and has the power
to make businesses successful like I
want it to be a shark yeah someone who's
actually powerful yeah I don't need to
know their name I want maybe a new name
yeah what if we threw a new name into
the mix maybe like a single businessman
who goes on to be a businessman for
someone love
love love so that's what's going on in
the tank the tank has been shaken up
Shake It Up Shark Tank I have to tell
Zach I wonder if he knows he never
misses an episode and he loves Mark but
also like the news wasn't big I saw it
in like a random tweet and I was like is
this real and then I had to like search
so it hasn't been because there wasn't
an official statement or anything he
just said it on a podcast he said it on
a podcast that that's what he was
feeling I don't think he realized it was
like going to be as big of AAL thing
that it is but it's he's still on this
season he's going to do next season so
it's we have time we have time our next
story Kylie Jenner says her and Jordan
never fully cut each other off after the
Tristan Scandal so Kylie Jenner did an
interview with Jennifer Lawrence for
interview magazine and she talked about
how um her relationship with Jordan has
transpired over the years she said
Jordan and I we always stayed in touch
throughout the years and we would meet
up at my house and catch up and just
talk through everything we never fully
cut each other off and one day naturally
we were like we want to get sushi and we
don't want hide anymore the sushi outing
occurred in July 2023 when they stepped
out for a fun girl's night the outing
Sushi Park the outing sent the internet
into a frenzy but it appeared the pair
had been on good terms for some time
however that doesn't mean the Scandal
didn't impact their friendship at all
Kylie noted that she and Jordan who were
once Inseparable decided they needed a
slight break from each other following
the incident she said there's a Learning
lesson in everything and I think that in
a weird way everything happens how it's
supposed to happen we were so attached
to the hip that we needed space to grow
into the people that we were supposed to
be I needed that Independence and that
confidence because she was like my
security blanket for so long yeah like
their relationship was like unhealthy
for like grown girls like having
sleepovers every night they live
together right so I agree with Kylie I
do I do want to say like when
celebrities get interviewed by like
other celebrities to me it's like such
an eye roll like just give the
journalist her job back you know but I
happen to love I read this Jennifer
Lawrence one like it was Jennifer
Lawrence was so excited asking such
funny questions snide commentary yeah
obsessed obsessed I was hoping there was
going to be a butt at the end of your
statement because yeah typically you
know like no it's Kim Kardashian by
Jennifer Lopez like why right no or it's
like scores on Swift yeah yeah like
why like I something that I happen to
just dislike it just kind of gives like
pretentious eye roll Vibes like I don't
like it also because it's not typically
done in a way that's really fun or
necessary and this was those things this
is just like a conversation and Jennifer
Lawrence did a great job what can't she
do yeah uh and like Jennifer Lawrence
clearly just watches the show and like
is a fan girl but is also friends with
them and she can't get over that she's
friends with them it was so relatable
and she's so funny and I thought she did
an excellent job so this is my exception
to my rule I agree does Jennifer
Lawrence have a movie coming out because
she's been out and about a lot that's
true she is but not that I know of I
mean she's not in Hunger Games right
that's crazy that she didn't go to the
Premiere I don't know it's like a new
generation like let them no but like she
is Hunger
Games she is Hunger Games that's true
actually like at this very moment I am
Hunger Games I'm starving what are you
can have for lunch I don't know it's so
hard I've just also like another reason
I'm excited to be like out of my house
like I have been just like a slob like I
have reverted to my old self these last
eight days like I have not worked out I
worked out once I have just been eating
crap like I literally ate a meatball sub
like I'm just living my life it was so
good but I'm like excited like I need to
like put if I want to feel good I have
to like put good things in my body like
I need to like like I walk to work like
I it's better reset I need I need to
have like a good healthy
lunch okay what does that
entail like a wrap is that healthy I
don't even
know wheat
wrap yeah by the way they only offer
wheat wraps now can we talk about that
like anytime I get a wrap they always
say you want whole wheed or spinach I'm
like what about white well you're just
talking about 40 karats which is no no
I'm not I'm not I also get wraps from
Chopped and lenwich actually lenwich has
white maybe I'll get lenwich today yeah
invite dat that's her favorite
restaurant in the city is it it would be
she loves their tuna you know how we're
always talking about on the toast how
there's a warm bowl place right by our
studio that I'm always not me literally
dreaming last night about the warm bowl
place you know I've been out of work for
too long because I haven't had it do you
think that was like your entrepreneurial
side kind of dreaming about opening up
tury worm bowls turties Bolero what did
we say we were G to call it tur turties
worm bowls yeah but then we then we
bowls change to something yeah whatever
maybe maybe it's you know I heard that
Mark was leaving and I saw an
opportunity to be a shark no or you have
to get on the tank before he leaves
that's a dream job but I would have to
be doing it with someone else's money
even if I imagined like I had all that
money I don't think I commit to a job
where I have to pay people you know no
but like you technically would make
money I would love to see see a
statistic of every shark how much
they've put out and what they've gotten
back I'm sure it's all net positive
because for one of them for all of them
at least one has hit really big to
negate all the other Investments yeah
like Lori will be in the green in
eternity because of Scrub Daddy yeah now
I know Mr Wonderful likes to claim that
he's got the biggest deal because the
guys who came on for plated didn't get a
deal but then he ran into them at a
conference later invested and they sold
to Albertson for I think $3 billion I
don't count billi it wasn't in the it
was in the bees yes it was played at
Albertson I don't think it was in the
bees maybe it was I thought it was in
the 100 Millions $175 million in cash oh
is that what Mr Wonderful got or that's
the whole deal that's the whole deal
okay but so someone else said 300
million okay but still not billions yeah
I think he likes to consider himself
like one of the biggest deals because of
that but I'm just I love Mr Wonderful
with my whole heart it doesn't count
that's like saying ring is the biggest
product to come off Shark
Tank well that's different because they
didn't end up getting a deal from any
shark right so it's like not a shark
tank product but plated did but the deal
wasn't done on air it doesn't count so
neither does
ring no I would never ring take credit
for ring no no it's crazy that none of
them gave him a deal yeah maybe I was
getting confused because that one sold
to Amazon for a billion dollars Amazon
owns ring yes but Amazon has their own
cameras Amazon has their own everything
who owns ring
Amazon Amazon wow that's a dream if we
could sell to any company it would
obviously be Amazon well yeah
right or like lvmh I think lvmh needs a
podcast in their portfolio i' would have
to think about it cuz you have to think
about like the other companies in their
portfolio like so you going to be
likees with right no lvmh is like so
fancy I don't think LV I wanted to tell
you something I fell down a Tik Tok
rabbit hole which was just perfect
timing cuz I thought you fell down I'm
sure I
did me and and it was like perfect
timing because me and Ben have been
watching we watch CIP girl all weekend
we're like halfway through season 3 um
and there was like a whole a couple
episodes about catian and like deadball
and then I ended up on this Tik Tok
Rabbit Hole apparently this weekend was
I want to get the exact wording because
you will love it Leal de Leal de debut
in I think Paris like the actual like
debutants of the world all had their
like coming out debutant Gala um and
there was so many Tik toks made about it
so it's like princesses ayses from all
over the world like there was one girl
from America she was so cute and she's a
descendant of Henry Ford Gerald Ford
what's his name Ford Ford motor
Henry Henry uh was he also President
Gerald Ford was the vice president or
president no motor motor Queen motor
Henry Ford she was so cute
anti-semite Henry Ford mhm oh my God to
see it they'd be ruining fat one a big
fat anti-semite was he fat no oh just
the anti-Semitism was yes yes I don't
think if he was fat I would have called
him fat yeah no that he can be
anti-semitic but I can't be fat phobic
no right right it's so true um and so
they all wore like Ure like atellier
custom and they were all just like
beautiful and the gowns and and they're
all just like models it was honestly
I'll send you a Tic Tac of like all the
looks and somebody did like here's who
each of them are like here their parents
AR send me send me the ro oh my God what
a fabulous place to have been that's so
fabulous please sent me the assets I
hope some love matches were made though
like what is the point it's like them
these are like aristocratic gires who
like there is actual Society there so
these type of events are archaic for us
but for them like they still exist in
those types of like you're coming out
you're eligible yeah I guess they still
do that in America 2 like a dead ball
where you're coming out like yeah but
that one's like a little like pointless
no that's what I'm saying but this one's
not like now we know about all these
girls like they're they're being brought
to the world for you know dating for for
we didn't
know right okay that's that's really
cool please send it to me also speaking
of aier gorgeous royal fashion do you
see black pink at Buckingham Palace I
didn't but I heard see you have to see
their looks Claud Google it did you see
some news that came out was that Taylor
Swift had of course I think we had
assumed this she had been offered
coronation and she said no for Charles
why' she say no
I'm sure she's busy and or
disinterested but you know she could get
up there and sing you know I love a
London boy I enjoy nights in brickton
shortage in the afternoon he likes my
American smile like a child when our
eyes meet daring I fancy you took me
back to H met all of his best mates so I
guess all the rumors are true you know I
love a London
boy
boy I fancy you she also could sing king
of my
heart oh my God she could sing king of
my heart I have an eye twitch sorry like
I just need to hold my eye open there's
so many songs she could sing I wish she
performed and was she still dating Joe
then yeah by the way this dumb question
did he already have his Carnation no it
was in a car you were thinking of
Jubilee no but there was something that
people didn't perform at or did it
already happen and we missed it maybe I
just was the Carnation no was it not
memorable
no there was like yeah he had Jubilee
was one thing which was amazing but
there was another
thing his
coronation yeah it was in May yeah and
like that's so crazy like I don't even
remember it
irrelevant no but we had so many
conversations about like where's Harry
Styles where's Ed cheran where Adell
yeah but I felt like we had those
conversations also about the Jubilee oh
yeah but the Jubilee was
amazing amazing is how I felt about it
and also something else about tailored
that I forgot what I was going to say
but I've really been enjoying the 1989
Vault tracks me too do you would you say
they're the best Vault tracks it's
really hard to beat red we'll take out
all two out 10 minut version okay we
still got
better man MH we still got babe which
were songs we already knew we still got
Message in a Bottle it's really hard but
also I've had way more time to ruminate
with red ask me in a year okay I think
the 1989 ones are my favorite but I also
didn't listen to speak now ones not even
all of fearless definitely all of red
though yeah the fearless and the speak
now ones in my opinion don't compete
they're really good ones from each like
when Emma falls in love is so good but
as a whole they don't compete with red
or 1989 okay cool you didn't send me
that Tik Tok I was looking for I know I
forgot sorry I've been a little busy
that's okay I'm sure you'll find the
time by the way the breakout star from
that debut t ball I just found on my Tik
Tok her name is Lara Kima where's she
from let let me tell you exactly who she
is but she's like viral now Lara Kima
hankle Von doners
smark
does she have a Tik Tok of her own she
does that's how I found her whole name
she has 83,000 followers oh no that's on
Instagram but I just want to know like
who she
is yeah and she has almost 300K on on um
Tik
Tok oh here yeah hello magazine best
dressed at the debutant ball 23 Lara
kosa was on there but they'll tell me
who she is hold
on oh yeah princess lissy salassi so
many good people yeah yeah Lara Connor
looked good is she American no she we
Carolina Herrera I think she is American
send me the link drop a
link oh my God wait I'm just reading
about all the girls this girl Lara
Connor she's stunning so Lara danced
into the labal de debutant in a colorful
tool gown by Carolina Herrera the
19-year-old fashionista is currently
pursuing a degree in government at
George Georgetown University and um her
mother is a contributor at Vogue Lara's
best friend Patrick Bennett is her
Cavalier King Charles okay so Countess
Lara Kima she's a CEST this girl who's
like kind of the breakout star she wore
jeanal gotier her gown embodied the
signature silhouette of Go's
o CEST Lara kosa is the daughter of
Oscar winning film director Florian henl
Von doners Mark best known for writing
and directing the lives of others which
gained an Academy Award in 2007 the
20-year-old oh she's German German star
has built her own Tik Tok Empire gaining
40 million views okay she is is 300,000
followers let's just CM down um over two
months oh I'm sorry over two months oh
she got popular on Tik Tok cuz she was
doing like day in my life while she was
inter turning for like big fashion
brands cool and she's a countess where
does the Countess come from from the
Oscar winner I don't know also the arch
Duchess of Austria and the royal
princess of Hungary that's both the same
girl that's her title her name is ILO
hapsburg hapsburg she's
HSB luing again she's an imperial and
royal princess embodied Regal Beauty in
a petrol blue Alex mobile gown she
stepped into the spotlight wearing the
or Orleans
Tiara oh wait they keep saying
Cavalier oh I feel like oh I feel like
Cavaliers we're thinking dog I think
Cavaliers is who escorted them because
the other one said Patrick Bennett I was
like wait her dog is a first 10 last
name so her Cavalier is hrh Prince
Constantine de Orleans so Cavalier is
obviously like your your date or your
dog no no no no no no no can you tell me
this link please yeah it's so
interesting no yes wait I'm texting it
to you I also feel like looking at the
descendants of Royals not that we have
that many it's a good way to know what
like the old Royals used to look like
cuz we don't have photos but I'm sure
some of them look like their
grandparents or great grandparents and
then that's like a way to know what CeCe
looked like so jasman Yen of China she
wore an ult Couture gown she's a
musician she's studied at the Berkeley
music of College of Music um it's just
so
interesting oh and there was a Jew she
was my favorite titha Stern what color
is her dress black oh British debutant
ttha Stern hails from banking royalty
her ancestors can trace their Roots back
to 17th century Merchant Bankers in
Frankfurt and have been Founders and
shareholders in leading Banks God this
just reads like like an anti-semitism
some propaganda
like she's 17 years old she wore
Christian Dior she's an avid ski racer
her proudest achievement to date is
being named the anglo-scottish winner of
both the giant slalom events in 2023 and
she made it to the top 20 in the French
national skiing
championships wow she's so cute she
looks like a girl I went to Camp with
who's a
billionaire isn't this interesting it
is oh this I guess there was more than
one American theer Isa was Ellie
Mah okay who's she she um I believe is
the
Ford she hailed her proudest
achievements as winning the under 25
racing cars Grand Prix in Canada her
Cavalier is from Scotland he's a
marquis of Lauren who wore his family
Kilt to the ball okay so a cavaliere is
a human yeah yeah yeah oh no I'm sorry
that wasn't Ford there there's actually
quite a few Americans a Olivia Ford
ueli she wore Oscar dear Renta her
status is defined by her beloved
grandmother Anne Ford a direct
descendant of American inventor and
industrialist Henry Ford whose
achievements are seen by many as the
epitome of the American dream she was
raised in Beverly Hills with her sister
and her best friend Elanor who took part
in the ball last year and she now lives
in New York City where she is a student
at
NYU wow no this is just I won't read all
of them but you should go down the
rabbit hole it's extremely interesting I
will I will and I want to see Tik Tok um
so let's consider that our fourth story
shall we no let's not because I have
something to
do what do you have to do my dear friend
the remaining stories are brought to you
by Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from products to content
to time all in one place and all on your
own terms so you need a website
girlfriend I don't know if anybody's
told you this recently but you're trying
to build a business side hustle an
e-commerce website whatever it is you
need a website and it needs to look good
but you don't have to pay a bunch of
money for that Squarespace has got you
covered they' have all different product
features whatever type of website you're
trying to build whether you're trying to
create an asset Library so if you're a
photographer or a videographer who wants
to Showcase their portfolio and be able
to send that to people when trying to
book gigs you need that you want to sell
merch you can do that easily easily sell
custom merch create passive income that
engages your audience and scales your
brand do you want to create an online
store you're getting into e-commerce you
can do that sell your products on an
online store with square space they have
flexible website templates that'll look
super professional but you can do them
all yourself it will look like you paid
a company lots of money but you didn't
it was just you in
Squarespace um also what I love about
Squarespace if you're using it to sell
stuff is they have a point of sale where
you can sell in person by connecting a
square reader to the Squarespace app so
you'll be able to keep your orders
inventory customer data in sync with all
the orders you've been taking online so
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain so that's squarespace.com get the
free trial and once you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com toast and
you'll save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or a domain today's episode
is also brought to you by
seed so seeds DS1 daily symbiotic is a
broadspectrum probiotic and Prebiotic
formulated with 24 clinically and
scientifically studied strains for Whole
Body Benefits including gut skin and
heart health feel like everybody's
obsessed with their gut health and it's
like where do we start what's a
probiotic what's a Prebiotic I feel like
seed is a great place to start the ds01
daily symbiotic is formulated based on a
robust clinical and mechanistic
mechanistic research that includes the
biologically active dose of each strain
and ensures that the full dosage of live
bacteria survives and remains viable
through digestion or the trip to your
doorstep so a lot of people have taken
probiotics or prebiotics and find that
they don't work and that's because a lot
of times it doesn't even survive your
digestive tract but seed has got you
covered they ensure that they will
always make it through your digestive
tract and so what's the benefit of
getting your gut health in check well
most importantly big soft duties I think
that's important for a lot of people
right in the morning um also there's a
lot of skin benefits if you're feeling
like your skin is really clogged guts
your gut just really can control a lot
of things in your
body um and we love seed it's been
working amazing pooping every day
feeling good digestion on fleek they're
going to promote healthy regularity and
stool quality and it can provide relief
from occasional digestive discomfort
bloating and intermittent constipation
so seeds DS1 daily symbiotic is that
[__] visit seed.com toast and use code
toast to redeem 25% off your first month
of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic that's seed
seed.com toast and use code toast thank
you la you're welcome fa our next story
a little update on the movements of one
tailored Swift she has flown back to
Kansas City to visit Travis after
finishing her Brazil ARS tour shows so
after a rough round of arist tour shows
in Brazil the singer landed in Missouri
on Monday to visit her boyfriend Travis
Kelce she touched down at the private
airport after taking off from Florida 2
hours earlier and Florida yeah she must
have flown from Brazil to maybe she
needs to refuel
perhaps well you know what she doesn't
have shows for a while and like I think
she needs to relax like she needs to
just lay with her boyfriend be in love
go out to romantic dinners in a small
town it's literally a novel it writes
itself while she recharges for the next
couple of shows like I feel like it's
been all about Taylor you know so now
let it be about Travis this is important
we're almost coming to the playoffs like
she can be supportive girlfriend I feel
like the timing's actually working out
nicely and I don't think she has shows
like until the Super Bowl yeah that's
what I think too not certainly not till
next year so she's able to spend the
holidays how she pleases oh where are
they going to spend the holidays by the
way Christmas Day football is like a
thing right or is it basketball
football okay so should we check his
schedule yeah yeah
yeah I'm so hungry wow just felt like
sharing okay do you think other people
talk about like how hungry they are on
their podcast no certainly on Smart list
all they talked about was food oh and on
good guys and on good
guys
okay okay here December 18th Chiefs
Patriots at Patriots I feel like it
doesn't say but I feel like whoever goes
second I feel like it's a home game oh
really I think it was whoever goes first
no cuz you say it like how does it go
Chiefs then Patriots so you would say
chiefs at Patriots okay
hold on when they played the Eagles
where did they
play Philly and Philly was first in
the oh it says Eagles Chiefs so first
place is where they play look at us
deductive reasoning I don't know if like
I believe that honestly like that
doesn't make any sense it's the opposite
it's the opposite so it's
what who's home Kansas Patriots Kansas
at Patriots so you were right yeah I was
right so then the the Eagles played the
chief in Kansas then City okay Kansas
City Missouri maybe I was wrong about
that I don't know so Chiefs at Patriots
oh my God in New England December 18th
like that's oh they could go to Rhode
Island they could go to Rhode Island oh
that's the perfect place to spend the
holidays yeah then December 25th they
have a um Christmas game but it's at
Kansas City oh okay so like they before
but his and hers his and hers wait
that's that's what's so nice about
having like such a robust real estate
portfolio while dating an NFL player
like oh are we playing the Tennessee
Titans off to my Mansion oh the Rams are
the Chargers or maybe even the 49ers off
to my Pache in Los Angeles like all the
New York teams bills Jets Giants I don't
know about bills it's a little far she's
a plane yeah yeah yeah bills Giants
Jets I would even put like New England
Boston Philly in the New York area
Philly for sure but then so uh Christmas
game at Kansas City so they could be in
Kansas City for Christmas and then New
Year's Eve game at Kansas City also New
Year's Eve December 31st who the [__]
watches football on New Year's Eve it's
lit going to be us Sunday it's GNA be us
oh my God yeah we'll all be together
watching football we haven't watched
football together in so long the boys
are going to be so annoyed with us okay
you know what Ben was trying to explain
something to me last night because we
were watching this honestly terrible
game Vikings
verse Cincinnati B
um and so one of the teams was like down
by three or whatever but the the losing
team had three timeouts I but so they
like used the timeouts Ben was trying to
explain it to me I don't understand
timeouts like are they not just a chance
to like get water and sit down no
they're like strategic you use them to
like run the clock yeah I so don't
understand it Ben was trying to explain
it to me he made it so confusing like he
Jackie he might as well have been
speaking Chinese like I seriously did
not understand one word he was talking
about so I like I think I should ask
Shapiro like maybe Shapiro could explain
it better so I'll ask him when we're all
together or somebody wants to explain it
in the comments like I could not
understand it for the life of me one
thing at a time tury one thing at a time
wait so that's like such a fun end of
year for Taylor like hopefully those are
her plans Holiday House Kansas City
maybe Trav home his new house already
maybe for sure for sure rich people move
quickly yeah but they also like do work
to the house yeah but Travis is not that
kind ofy like oh somebody built a nice
mansion with a pool and a waterfall I'm
moving in totally he's the type who like
literally brings a pillow and a
toothbrush yeah let me pack my things
and like his Louis Vuitton deel yeah and
like Taylor's so in love like she
wouldn't
care yeah but she's also like you know
she's not gonna add too much commentary
at this point in the relationship she
doesn't want to see high maintenance
yeah she's just going to go with the
flow oh Trav I love your house you know
what a cute stripper pole your brown
comforter yeah no like no headboard not
a problem Black Sheets cool I love black
very reputation era VI
Travis are you ready for our fifth and
final story some publishing
drama you probably haven't heard of it I
thought it was so funny Sports
Illustrated is accused of publishing AI
generated copy and using head shots
created by Ai and Publishing fake writer
profiles so Sports Illustrated has been
accused of publishing AI generated
writing while using head shots of fake
authors and creat creating bogus
profiles the Legacy magazine was called
out for the content which was allegedly
written by non-existent authors Sports
Illustrated said that the word came from
a third party who assured their articles
were written by humans an investiga an
investigation conducted found that
multiple authors with biography pages on
Sports Illustrated website were fake
including madeup interest hobbies and
even an AI created headshot as well as
the author some of the writing on the
website's review page was accused of
sounding like it was written by an alien
with bizarre bcri bizarre descriptions
and formatting discrepancies
so some of the um things that were found
Drew Ortiz an alleged writer had on his
profile that he has spent much of his
life outdoors and is excited to guide
you through his NeverEnding list of the
best products to keep you from falling
to The Perils of nature it's so funny
when you read stuff that's like and you
realize it's AI generated it makes no
sense what were we reading
recently when when we were designing our
merch website is that what you're
thinking
about
there were just like some blurbs that
were placeholders that were like clearly
written by AI they made no sense no
sense in like the footer where you would
normally put like your return policy
they just like put some words from it it
was so funny oh my God wait I think I I
might I must have screenshot they wrote
something about war did they hold on
yeah sign up to get updates on new
releases and things toast like that's
sentence no by the way I just want to
say like I know AI is the devil y y here
oh doing collections doing fashion is
like a Non-Stop
dialogue War taught me war taught me
that not everything is glamorous luxury
will always be around no matter what
happens in the world I don't care about
money I really don't care I just want to
do what I do
I I love to design things that people
can actually buy I'm staggered what
[Music]
a I'm staggered by what a boot costs
today
what I'm obsessed and we thought AI
Couldn't Write comedy wait I just want
to
say I know AI is like the devil whatever
a a company like Sports Illustrated
spending any money on writing is just a
waste like no one's going to Sports
Illustrated for the thought-provoking
Articles like they're going to look at
pictures of beautiful women and you know
sports stuff like I think it's fine
Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue only
happens once a year though like the rest
of it is about sports are you sure like
articles about sports yeah I didn't feel
like that's like not true no no no it's
like shockingly true I think like go to
sportsillustrated.com am what's the big
headline is it bikini models or is
it sportsillustrated.com
NFL Power Rankings Eagles 49ers headed
for top two Showdown what I'm shocked
yeah it's all it looks like
espn.com oh my God I'm literally shocked
how irrelevant are they like in that
regard they had people writing like
articles I guess if it's like a recap of
a game like okay
yeah yeah but they got caught so it
obviously wasn't very good it was kind
of like our merch blurbs yeah yeah it
was staggering how much a boot cost
today
yeah it by the way it is staggering how
much your boot costs today it's
staggering how much everything
costs 100% anyways um so that's a little
embarrass for Sports Illustrated that is
embarrassing um but I think this might
be something we see a lot but like other
Publications will learn from this like
they will proofread it and have like a
copywriter make it look normal but AI is
also getting smarter like give them time
also did you see the most recent AI
drama we talked about this on the
patreon of Thanksgiving Day topics about
chat GPT Sam mman but then did you see
this like letter that came out about Sam
oh no what is he not the good
guy I don't know it was like an
anonymous it no one tied their name to
the letter because they're all like so
scared of him they say but they said
like there but but hundreds of other
employees wrote a letter begging the
board to put him back on they love him
you just should read the other letter
okay for sure I'm I'm more inclined to
trust a letter that's positive that's
signed by so many people no nobody force
him to sign this letter than one
Anonymous troll what it wasn't one it
wasn't one it was just another side to I
just said we said on the pat like has
say more to the story like what did so
what did they say about him um toxic
work environment so scary you know
threatening employees blah blah blah all
okay toxic workplace has just become
like one of those words that lost its
meaning mhm cuz there are workplaces
that are incredibly toxic to be at I
feel like somebody somebody got
reprimand somebody got reprimanded once
on slack and they were like this is a
toxic workplace like grow up a little
bit so I need to know if it's a
workplace that is toxic or a toxic
workplace I don't know fear of speaking
out
retribution yada yada all right I'll
have to read both letters yeah everyone
has a letter to right to write and
everyone has a letter to read but don't
touch the Morgan letters that's the
first Ru of letters that the first rule
of letters is don't touch the Morgan
ones and if you can can live by that
you'll be okay you'll be safe you'll be
okay you'll make it
through well we made it through a great
episode so good to be back with you
we're back tomorrow and the day after
that and the day after that only a
couple more weeks before our end of
season so our it up our last episode for
the year of season six is this
six I don't know I think it
is yeah let me check right maybe that's
crazy that's like so crazy we'd be going
to our seventh season and we don't like
make up Seasons like people do like two
months of podcast like that's season one
no season is a whole year it's like a 10
episode season they do it's like so
crazy cuz I remember when we started
this season because every time I wrote
the episode I had to like change from
season five to six and I was like damn
it's going to be taking me so long to
remember to do
this were you able to find it I don't
know
we're doing a lot of like looking on our
phones today we're finally doing what
people want us to
do whatever um so our last episode of
the year is December 16th it's slowly
approaching so just prepare yourself
because we ain't back till the new year
so they'll be patreon of course because
this is oh business and we'll also we'll
all be together yeah lots of content
lots of everyone's getting at my Tik
toks I don't care I don't care I have to
drag them by their hair I'll work on my
moves the Renegade oh yeah yeah it's
giving 2019 it's giving Tik Tock thank
you guys so much for listening to the
toast Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories you need
to know every Monday the Friday YouTu
watching on YouTu pleas subscribe thumbs
up Avail
podcast podcast beautiful Wily talented
we are have a great day everyone we'll
see you tomorrow love you
bye